well you know it's interesting if if he
came in and told me the nuclear codes
right and said I'm about to to take out
New York City well then yeah I would
probably lose my license to practice law
if I turned him
in my name is Doug Ridley and I'm a
criminal defense
attorney you know it's an interesting
time right now to be dealing with Doc
and stealing documents or having
documents that you're not supposed to
have or having suitcases in the corner
with documents that you're not supposed
to have Ethan Hunt gets in a ton of
trouble if he is arrested and prosecuted
for stealing that knock list now
obviously my defense of Ethan is going
to be that he was protecting it that he
wasn't stealing it he was moving it to a
safer location and that is really his
intention he's not taking it stealing it
for his own uses or stealing it for
nefarious uses he's really trying to
protect all of the things that he does
to get in is breaking it entering it's
burglary it's it's all of the uh really
cool Heist stuff that happens absolutely
is 100% illegal there's no question that
he would be prosecuted for the breaking
and entering and all of those things but
I like the argument that he was just
doing it to protect the list so I would
be uh happy to make that argument for on
his
defense interestingly enough there are
rules in place that allow law
enforcement officials to use what they
call aruse in interrogation and even
though we see all of these masks and all
these elaborate sets I mean that's a
level that's way above and beyond what
we would typically see it's not uncommon
for law enforcement to use ause like hey
the guy in the other room uh just gave
us a full confession and pointed the
finger at you the whole way yes that is
not an accurate statement but case law
and our rules in the criminal justice
system allow law enforcement to make
those decisions and to act in that way
it's a little distasteful and juries
tend to not like it very much but
there's nothing that automatically gets
those cases kicked out of court just
because a law enforcement officer used a
ruse in their investigation take that
basic rule and apply that towards what
we see in Mission Impossible using the
ruse of a mask or using the ruse of a of
a set I think that if I'm trying to
protect those convictions as a
prosecutor I'm going to be arguing that
that is no different than me saying hey
we have you on video doing everything so
it's a really good idea for you to tell
us the truth now it's not that much of a
different sort of a
situation
collaborate with
him and it's Christmas the lawyer client
privilege is sacred so anything that
Ethan tells me or tells his priest or
tells his therapist those are the three
or his doctor you know those are the
areas that confidentiality and privilege
are just deemed to be absolute who's in
the file Russian nuclear launch
codes well you know it's interesting if
if he came in and told me the nuclear
codes right and said I'm about to to
take out New York City well then yeah I
would probably lose my license to
practice law if I turned him in I have
to weigh at that point the ethics of is
my license to practice law worth you
know A Million Lives if somebody tells
me that they're going to go rob a liquor
store then of course I have to keep that
confidential but there is a moral issue
that can come into play uh but the
ethics of it the ethics of whether
lawyers have to keep those conversations
confidential is black and white it's
it's not that complicated at all we have
to keep those those conversations
confidential so I would have to keep all
of Ethan's Secrets no matter what
the best example of this is looking at
law enforcement law enforcement has
immunity for what they do in the uh
guise of their official duties as law
enforcement if they are going through
and and concluding an investigation if
they're doing what we would typically
expect law enforcement to do then what
happens as a result of that they have
immunity for but they're also required
to obey a set of rules and a set of laws
and that doesn't change necessarily
because you're an agent versus your
local law enforcement they have to
follow a set of rules they're not
allowed to go and kill people or commit
terrible crimes or anything along those
lines what we do see Ethan do yeah he
lies yeah he wears masks yeah he
deceives people he absolutely kills
people but if it's in the realm of
working that mission they do have a
license to carry out a lot of that some
of the stuff that he does is really
problematic and I have to believe that
there are some checks and balance is
that I guess we don't really get to know
all about just being regular civilians
that we are but I I I do think that that
Ethan is going to be called to the
carpet for violating a lot of the
procedures that he's supposed to follow
uh but I I don't see that ever coming
into court for us ever I don't I think
that would stay pretty
quiet I think anything that is destroyed
by the government you can file a claim
and you can get reimbursement for so
when he takes out a parking garage if my
car is parked in there you can bet that
Monday morning I'm going to go in and
I'm going to file a claim and I'm going
to make the government pay for my car
and if their defense on that is that
well it was caused by a disavowed agent
uh that's not going to carry any weight
they they're they're going to be
responsible for paying for me I'm going
to make them pay for my parking garage
for my car for whatever it is that they
cause damage for at the end of the day
the government is responsible for for
their agents and for their employees and
what their employees do to cause another
civilian damage they're responsible to
pay
for there isn't a specific punishment
for faking your own death but I think
that the steps that lead up to it could
potentially have some sort of punishment
if you're forging government documents
if you are lying the LA enforcement if
you are aligned to government Personnel
those sorts of things potentially have
some level of criminal culpability
involved with it but just the the
general aspect of Faking your own death
if you can avoid those other potential
procedural legistic pitfalls there's not
a specific crime related to faking your
own death not at least that that Ethan
would be subject to and and certainly I
mean Ethan I I think he's going to be
faking his own death a lot more time
times I don't know how many times he's
going to be successful in even
accomplishing something like that I'm
afraid today is the day when the imf's
luck runs
out when we're looking at the IMF and
assuming that it's closest to
CIA Ethan Hunt knows way too much for
that agency to allow him to take the
stand go public and deal with the cases
that way we obviously don't know a whole
lot about how the CIA might resolve
cases with Rogue agents because we don't
hear a whole lot about that which makes
me believe we probably wouldn't hear a
whole lot about that I have a feeling
that basically what we would be looking
at is Ethan getting like he does all the
way through getting getting disavowed
getting bumped down and potentially
being held liable maybe in another
country where they wouldn't have the
right to publicize his trial and maybe
wouldn't have the right to uh him giving
a spe on the courthouse steps and
sharing everything he knows there are
probably some countries that the IMF is
affiliated with that would do them a
favor of taking him into custody there I
have a feeling that that's probably the
way that story would
[Music]
end